et bien bonjour et bienvenue dans cette
deuxième vidéo sur le japon nous sommes
actuellement un fils jean aux miens
c'est un peu la campagne j'ai jamais vu
la campagne japonaise bas là je suis et
vu que les hôtels ça ne se lit comme
vous pouvez le voir on va dormir dans
une caravane aménagée attention petit
tour des lieux
ici il ya juste un lac qui est de
l'autre côté qui s'appelle le lac tanuki
qui est très très beau c'est parti pour
chill et pendant 24 heures bon vu qu'il
a à faire nous sommes passés à un
magasin et j'ai acheté tous les jouets
que le magasin propose est élevé
japonais jeux japonais à voir s'il a
estimé leo seeger j'ai fait presque et
ça fait des bulles
ah oui je les prenne au total meilleur
outil c'était l'un des plus beaux
moments du japon attend mais c'est
pourri mon verger petit note robert
médecin alors même eric tuboeuf colucci
m ok jeu suivant florent l'attention
autant je me suis gouré
j'ai acheté deux jouent avec les bulles
on peut faire une battle de game de
bulles du coup on au japon le japon
c'est quoi c'est nintendo nintendo c'est
quoi ces pokémon jeter enchaîné c'était
super chiant bon on veut tous dracaufeu
si c'est la crise a brouillé les normes
c'est quoi ça un pokémon c'est un une
appli mobile qui polit pokémon qui
copient pokémon barça c'est génial pour
soirée chez mamie qu'on avait 8 ans
encore à l'époque on avait deux game boy
mais y'avait grâce pokémon à sa mamie
elle va en acheter au marché florent
flonflons touché à pied en matière du
monde emmerdes attend au au maire
oh [ __ ] falloir aller moi toi
[Musique]
maintenant c'est l'heure de passer au
dernier jouait ses 1ers japonais je n'ai
pas fait beaucoup et mais que voilà aube
et invest-at flèche pasqua dans cet
endroit là une pokéball et on a à peu
tard on viendra tous les jeux nous
occuper 30 minutes on va faire une autre
qui le mont et puis je pense qu'on va
faire à la voir
[Musique]
bonjour très chers amis il est
actuellement 6h14 du matin je me lève
pour pouvoir aller filmer au drone le
lever de soleil au dessus du mont fuji
tout est prêt sauf mon cerveau qui est
encore en train dormait alors allons-y
[ __ ] a trop de chance aujourd'hui il
fait mais gabon va pouvoir admirer le
mont fuji mais comme jamais au quai gelé
devant moi c'est totalement
impressionnants le mont fuji
c'est tellement ou d'avoir un truc aussi
imposant devant soi j'ai toujours
l'impression que j'allais tout aussi
gros que c'est des photographies on a
mis devant moi ou c'est juste une plaque
de contreplaqué géante et on n'a pas un
truc dessus
[Musique]
et voilà j'espère que ce petit réveil en
compagnie du mont fuji vous aura plu
ensuite va pas tarder à bouger vers
notre prochaine destination
à savoir à koné à tout à l'heure
surprise nous venons d'arriver à hakone
dans notre riz aux calmes c'est un hôtel
trèbes de type tradition autrement
appelé quand c'est par les français est
un hôtel traditionnel du coup c'est
vraiment ambiance japon à base de
petites portes coulissantes à base de
petites tables basses basse mais surtout
à base de own scène sur la terrasse est
ce qu'on se met pas tous cuits vo chars
au programme on fait quoi où monsieur
layton les katanas qui sur un contre sk
racistes à yukata mon cher flanc et oui
et il s'agit de la tenue traditionnelle
pour hommes beaux jours m e thierry et
vous maniez le kung fu le confronte à
mon style chef au mondiaux ici on a un
mois d'un train de pratiquer le yoga
mais qu'il est beau [ __ ] nous sommes
le matin et aujourd'hui nous allons à
yokohama la dernière destination du
voyage avant toquero j'entends chars se
levait attention
pour aller les gars me fouette le petit
déjeuner dans 30 minutes
mais en attendant je propose tout
simplement d'avoir extrêmement froid le
temps de rentrer dans ce qu'on appelle
un mécène excellent jeu de mots même au
japon
c'est chaud j'espère vous là ça brûle je
vais vous mettre là on est bien là on
met l'ambiance tamisée poser est donc en
fait à hakone il ya plein de sources
naturelles au chaud il y en a sept je
crois différents lots en scène comme
dans cet hôtel en fait ils poutre dans
ses sources chaudes et abel l'eau ici il
fait que ces shows fait naturellement et
qui a dû souffrir dans l'eau ici à le
froid plus à faire y'avait singes qui se
sont appropriés certaines sources d'eau
chaude jordan ans et vivent dedans
du coup d'aller te baigner dans un bain
en pleine nature tu peux aller regarder
les singes se baigner dans un bang la
nature
bon allez c'est parti pour yokohama
[Musique]
bienvenue à yokohama ville portuaire à
ses proches de tokyo 40 minutes en train
j'ai révisé on vient d'arriver plus un
truc qu'on va faire c'est prendre un
bateau pour aller à chinatown que le
quartier chinois de yokohama est tout
simplement ou fais partie
et voici la porte du quartier chinois
trois choses qu'on trouve dans un
quartier chinois je suis moi ouais mais
c'est chez moi
well et auchan voilà on a d'autres
choses bien joué
[Musique]
et oui jamie je suis ici au musée du
ramène fini le quartier chinois jamais
rien à raconter là bas donc je vais
raconter ça c'est plutôt logique juste
bouffe mais ici on va pouvoir fabriquer
nos propres nous y mon gars est ce que
ce n'est pas le rêve de tout bon fan du
japon avoir ses propres ramène ses
parties un petit doute sur le musée dans
lequel on aime et je crois que ces
musées y aura même fait et non ce n'est
pas un homme qui va bouger comme on
s'approche de lui en espérant gagner une
pièce mais c'est bel et bien le créateur
du ramène merci beaucoup
ok c'est ici comme un créneau ramène la
première étape c'est d'acheter sa coupe
ok donc l'étape suivante est la pire de
toutes pour moi parce qu'on va faire un
petit dessin au dos de la coupe arrêt on
connaît mon skill en dessin
m
non
et voilà j'ai terminé le kawaï et ramène
comme on dit dans le milieu et les
classes laval mène pas vous savez
maintenant de qui je tiens tout mes jeux
de mots reste qu'au départ on se
tournait pas autour de nous use beaucoup
on lui donne notre peau il faut tourner
la manivelle comme celui ci est fait on
va choisir ce qu'on veut mettre dans le
ramène en plus des papes et il ya
énormément de choix
j'ai droit de choisir un seul coup j'ai
pris goût au curry et maintenant faut
que choisissent entre 4 petit ingrédient
le poussin un peu de trucs épices et je
mets des coeurs parce que c'est vraiment
une kawa et des swan est un peu de
plantes et 7,6 s'achève l'histoire du
kawaii ramène puisqu'ils vont ici le
faire mais il faudrait que je le beauf
sous 30 jours
et
allez rentrer à la maison ça a été super
dur à vivre tout ça pour les biens les a
mais c'est sur cette très belle vue
qu'on se quitte j'espère que ce deuxième
bloc n'a plus ces cas ne s'était pas
aimé la vidéo conneries tu cherches pas
pareil c'est froid on sent tout va très
vite pour d'autres aventures au japon au
revoir
[Musique]